[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok le changement c'est maintenant
le changement c'est maintenant
[Musique]
donc le changement c'est maintenant
frêche chose pour les frères
ok ok
je suis confiant je crois en toi en moi
on nous il est temps que les choses
changent dans ce monde de fous ne soit
pas que spectateur mais toi debout et
soient acteurs à ton échec car le
changement c'est nous je suis confiant
je vois en toi au moins
nous est temps que les choses changent
de ce monde
deux fous ne soit pas que spectacteur
et soient acteurs at-on échelle quand le
changement c'est nous
en le temps du réveil a sonné plus de
plastique de poisson mais selon les
données l'om est cela dit il ya plus de
gens qui meurent de marouf que de faim
certains diront que nous sommes très
proches de la fin mais moi j'y crois
encore et je le prouverai qui longtemps
si chaque personne à senteur fourni des
efforts et prend conscience que chaque
geste peut changer le décor le
changement c'est maintenant à raison ou
à temps plus le temps passe et plus la
marge de manoeuvre se réduit hier de mai
était loin maintenant c'est aujourd'hui
je veux moins d'assistanat et plus
d'autonomie énergétique alimentaire par
la sobriété guadeloupe l'île aux oiseaux
et aux talents gâchés passeur des
mauvais choix et des tonnes de déchets
mais sachez monsieur mesdames que je
crois en vous le changement est imminent
ça ne dépend que de nous je vois en toi
pour moi à nous il est temps que les
choses changent de ce monde de fous ne
soit pas que spectateur mais toi debout
et soit actera ton échelle quand le
changement c'est nous je suis confiant
je crois en toi
au moins on nous il est temps que les
choses changent dans ce monde de fous ne
soit pas que le spectateur nettoie
debout et soient acteurs at-on échelle
quand le changement c'est nous 1 quand
tu me parles d'énergie je te dis ouais
grave le ciel autonomie alimentaire je
réponds à quoi pony quand tu me parles
de déchets je te dirais consommer
consommer mieux
c'est simple à faire c'est seulement si
tu le veux mon île dans ce domaine a de
quoi faire des envieux
avec du soleil toute l'année bercé par
les alizés et quand tu me parles de
s'agace je réponds biomasse remarque
chaque problème peut avoir une solution
efficace
rappelant que planter un jardin c'est
quoi en des mains l'avenir peut être
plus beau hein
sur le tient demain 1 et si on le tient
à demain
je suis confiant je crois en toi moi en
nous il est temps que les choses
changent dans ce monde de fous ne soit
pas que spectateur mais toi debout et
soient acteurs at on une échelle quand
le changement c'est nous je suis
confiant je crois en toi moi en nous
[Musique]
le changement est imminent salle 2 cas
de nous que de nous excuser
ok
et si tulipes entre les lignes li entre
dessine façon autour de changement la
nature nous désigne que tu sois
sceptiques ou pas regardez-nous facile
et nous inspire
je te parle de biomimétisme pas besoin
de grands changements juste initiative
va ajouter couleurs atari com projet
solitaire préserver le patrimoine chaque
heure amène sa pierre
donc si je pense ou de toi je prends
soin de moi je pense ma nature donc je
prends soin de tous car des champions
soyons les leaders du développement
durable peut-être leur mettre une
maladie qu'on avait cru incurable je
suis confiant je vois en toi et moi
sommes nous il est temps que les choses
changent dans ce monde de fous ne soit
pas de spectateurs mais toi debout et
soit acteur a tourné chez elle quand le
changement c'est nous je suis confiant
je crois en toi en moi en nous il est
temps que les choses changent dans ce
monde de fous ne soit pas de spectateurs
nettoie debout et soient acteurs
tournent échelle quand le changement
c'est nous en évolution n'est pas
synonyme de destruction de destruction
oh yes d'innovation d'hier peut-être le
match d'aujourd'hui
faisons attention faisons attention je
reprends toi et en la richesse de mon
territoire
donc j'applique mes racines le vivant ça
me fascine je crois en toi au mois en
nous il est temps que les choses
changent dans ce monde de fous ne soit
pas que spectateur mais toi debout et
soit actera thoune échelle car le
changement c'est nous je suis confiant
je crois en toi moi on nous il est temps
que les choses changent dans ce monde de
fous ne soit pas que spectateur
mais toi debout et soie carton échelle
quand le changement c'est nous
car le changement c'est nous merci car
les changements c'est l'oubli
[Applaudissements]
car le changement c'est nous
e
merci pour
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]